en esta tabla tenemos que parar n igual
a 1 fm vale 12 cuando n vale 2 fn vale 5
para en igual a 3 fm vale menos 2 y para
n igual a 4 fn vale menos 9 y ahora ojo
esta función efe de n la podemos denotar
con una sucesión la podemos ver como una
sucesión en donde el primer término toma
el valor toma el valor de 12 en el
primer término tomamos el valor de 12 en
el segundo término tomamos el valor de 5
en el segundo tomamos el valor de 5 en
el tercer término tomamos el valor de
menos 2 el valor de menos 2 y en el
cuarto término tomamos el valor de menos
9 de menos 9 y bueno así nos podremos
seguir poniendo más y más y más términos
esto de aquí es nuestra sucesión ahora a
este tipo de sucesiones se les conoce
como sucesiones aritméticas date cuenta
de lo siguiente del 12 para el 5 lo que
hicimos fue restar siete después del 5
para el menos 2 lo que hicimos también
fue restar 7 y del -2 para el menos
nueve también lo que hicimos fue restar
7 así que cada término es 7 - que el
término anterior
ahora dado todo esto porque no buscamos
definir esta función
efe mn de una manera explícita es decir
pensando en la definición de una función
queremos encontrar a efe de n igual y
bueno tal que si ponemos aquí en esta
parte una n nos va a dar la apropiada
efe de n pensemos un poco en ello
bueno lo primero que quiero que te des
cuenta es lo siguiente
empezamos en 12 por lo tanto voy a poner
aquí un 12 y después le vamos a ir
quitando a este 12 7 veces cada vez que
tengamos un término más pero cuántas
veces le vamos a quitar al 12 7 bueno
justo aquí está la clave date cuenta de
lo siguiente cuando teníamos el primer
término nosotros nos quedamos con 12 por
lo tanto no le hemos quitado ninguna vez
7 en el término 2 lo que hicimos fue
quitar una vez 7 y por eso llegamos al 5
ahora en el término 3 lo que hicimos fue
quitar 12 veces 7 y por lo tanto
llegamos al menos 2 y cuando nosotros
nos fijamos en el término 4 lo que
hicimos fue quitar una dos tres veces 7
y así llegamos al menos 9 y eso lo
podemos escribir justo aquí en nuestra
función de la siguiente manera nos
fijamos en el término n y entonces vamos
a quitar n menos 1 veces 7
al 12 es decir si queremos un cierto
término vamos a quitar esa cantidad
menos 1 veces 7 al 12 para obtener
nuestro valor ahora veamos esta función
es la correcta para eso qué te parece si
vemos cuánto es
efe de 1 f1 me va a quedar 12 7 por 1 1
lo cual de 0 esto se cancele me quedaría
simple y sencillamente 2 que es justo
con lo que empezamos vamos bien
efe 2 bueno efe de 2 es lo mismo que 12
menos 7 que multiplica a 2 - 12 menos
uno es uno y entonces me quedaría 12
menos 7 lo cual de 5 o dicho de otra
manera le estoy quitando una vez 7 al 2
que era justo lo que tenemos aquí que
pasa con este de 3
bueno pues efe de 3 es lo mismo que
quitarle dos veces 7 al 12 y si te das
cuenta si yo pongo aquí el 3 me quedaría
3 - 1 lo cual es 2 y entonces 2
- 7 por 2 es lo mismo que quitarle 2
veces 7 al 12 así que parece que esta
función es la correcta y funciona muy
bien para definir de una forma explícita
esta sucesión que tengo que arriba así
que sería muy bueno ver otro ejemplo por
aquí déjame bajar la pantalla para que
veamos el siguiente ejemplo así que por
aquí está nuestro nuevo problema de lujo
en este caso tenemos algunas
definiciones de funciones ya escritas
aquí y bueno tenemos una asociación así
que recuerda que podemos ver esta tabla
como una sucesión podemos verla como la
sucesión déjame ponerlo aquí tenemos la
sucesión menos 100 después menos 50
después 0 después 50 y así podemos
seguir y seguir y seguir ahora lo que
quiero que veas es que es muy claro que
esta sucesión es una sucesión aritmética
pues empezamos en menos 100 y después de
menos 100 a 50 lo que hicimos fue
agregar 50 y después de menos 50 0 lo
que hicimos fue
al 50 y después de 0 50 lo que hicimos
fue agregar 50 estamos agregando la
misma cantidad así que el término
siguiente siempre es 50 más que el
término anterior lo que quiero que hagas
justo ahorita es que pausa es el vídeo y
piensas cuáles de estas definiciones son
correctas nota pueden ser más de una o
que pues pensemos los juntos la primera
definición de aquí dice bueno una forma
de pensarlo es decir voy a empezar en
menos 100 voy a empezar en menos 100 y
le voy a agregar 50 n menos 1 veces esto
tiene mucho sentido porque bueno date
cuenta que empezamos en menos 100 y aquí
qué es lo que pasaba en nuestro primer
término teníamos menos 100 y no
queríamos agregarle 50 porque queríamos
quedarnos aquí y bueno si aquí
sustituimos el uno me quedaría uno menos
uno lo cual es cero y entonces esto se
va y me quedaría menos 7 es decir no
estamos agregando 50 o dicho otra manera
estamos agregando 50 0 veces qué pasaría
con el segundo término bueno yo lo que
quiero aquí es
una vez 50 agregar una vez 50 y si
nosotros sustituimos el 2 aquí me va a
quedar dos menos uno es uno y aquí
entonces estaría agregando una vez 50
menos 100 más 50 por lo tanto parece ser
que está si funciona bastante bien
cuando yo quiero el tercer término aquí
tendría que agregar dos veces en cuenta
ya que no quedaría tres menos uno lo
cual es 22 veces 50 estaría agregándole
al menos cien y cuando n vale cuatro
bueno pues aquí me quedaría cuatro menos
uno lo cuales 33 veces en cuenta le
seguiría agregando al menos 100 esto
parece que funciona muy bien a mí fíjate
bien si yo quiero aquí el término 4 lo
que hice fue agregar una dos tres veces
50 para llegar a este valor y aquí me
quedaría 4 -1 lo cual de estrés
entonces me quedaría menos 100 más 50
por 3 o dicho de otra manera menos 100
más 3 bs 50 estoy agregando tres veces
50 así que en definitiva esta creo que
me gusta bastante
vayamos a la segunda fn es igual a menos
150 50 nm y bueno es que esta es otra
forma de decir que cuando n vale 1
entonces tendremos es más mejor déjame
hacer una tabla por aquí n
efe nm estamos en este caso de aquí y
déjenme hacer por aquí mi tabla ok vamos
a ver qué pasa con algunos valores de n
voy a poner a él como uno cuando n vale
1 bueno pues aquí me queda menos 150 más
50 por 1 así que esto se queda así y
esto es lo mismo que a menos 100 muy
bien entonces si checa perfecto qué pasa
cuando el nivel de 2 bueno me queda
menos 150 más 50 por 2 así que si te das
cuenta vamos a hacer esto
menos 50 menos 50 por lo tanto también
checa de lujo y cuando ande más de 3 ok
me va a quedar menos 150 más 50 por 3
por 3 lo cual es lo mismo que a estos
dos se cancelan me queda 0 también checa
con mi tabla por lo tanto parece ser que
es una buena opción bueno tú podrás
decir hey estas dos se ven muy distintas
pero tú puedes manipular la primera
algebraica mente para llegar a la
segunda y ver que son exactamente lo
mismo si tú tomas la primera y
distribuye es el 50 que te quedaría
bueno me quedaría menos 100 más se
encuentra por n lo cual me va a dar a 50
nm 50 n y después me queda se encuentra
x menos 1 lo cual es menos 50 y si
entonces te fijas que menos 100 menos 50
esto te da menos 150 y después aquí
tengo el 50 n entonces vas a ver que
estas dos son exactamente lo mismo por
lo tanto ésta
también funciona con algebraica mente la
misma definición ok veamos el tercer
caso fn es igual a menos 150 y bueno
veamos si funciona cuando en el balde
uno que me quedaría buenos quedaría
menos 100 más 50 pero menos 100 más 50
es lo mismo que menos 50 y yo quería un
menos 100 así que no no en definitiva
ésta no funciona por lo tanto ésta no va
a ser mi opción correcta